okay so as I've told you before the real
story the quote real story with Donald
Trump and stormy Daniels is not whether
Melania Trump knew that Trump was having
an affair or didn't know it's not
whether Trump used a condom as
interesting as I know that that's become
for a lot of people in our audience I've
seen the email some don't care some do
the really important part of the stormy
Daniels story is the possibly coercive
nature of these non-disclosure
agreements that are being used and
number two the potential illegality of
the hundred and thirty thousand dollars
in hush money that stormy Daniels was
paid there are a few different ways that
the hush money might have been illegal
the story were being told is that
because Michael Cohen likes Donald Trump
so much out of his friendship for Donald
Trump out of his genuine love for his
client Donald Trump he decided to cut a
check to stormy Daniels for a hundred
and thirty thousand dollars out of his
own money merely to get her to go away
and not talk about what of course they
maintain is a totally fake allegation of
an affair and he never even asked Donald
Trump for reimbursement to the hundred
and thirty thousand dollars and where it
gets really unbelievable is that Trump
is a billionaire how how many times over
there's disagreement about but I guess
we believe that Trump is a billionaire
Michael Cohen had to mortgage his house
or like get a home equity line of credit
in order to get that hundred and thirty
thousand dollars that he gave to stormy
Daniels and supposedly Donald Trump
never paid coming back maybe because he
had no idea about this it's laughable
right any clear-thinking person
recognizes that this makes no sense
whatsoever there is no chance in hell
that when your clients a billionaire you
just love him so much
that instead of just asking him to
reimburse you for the hundred and thirty
thousand dollars you mortgage your house
and never tell Donald Trump about it
it's totally not believable but Michael
Cohen's lawyer Cohen himself has
lawyered up right so Trump's lawyer is
Cohen Cohen has a lawyer named David
Schwartz David Schwartz has been going
around
any show that will listen that this is
the story no matter what logic dictates
and David Schwartz was interviewed on
the megyn kelly daily program the
daytime program for all my criticisms
about megyn kelly and this pretty stupid
daily show that he has she made David
Schwartz look really really stupid when
he told this story about a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars paid out of love
by Michael Cohen and it was so bad that
at one point the entire audience is just
laughing at the guy let's look at the
video it's worth seeing the whole way
through to just see how every time he
says it megyn kelly shows the total lack
of credibility that this story has and
business okay that's true but the weird
thing about this case is that Michael
Cohen signed the deal Donald Trump
didn't and you are claiming that Michael
Cohen the president's lawyer and fixer
ray Donovan character never ever told
Donald Trump about it never never never
told him and Michael Cohen dispensed one
hundred thirty thousand dollars of his
own money and never sought reimbursement
from Donald Trump under percent so the
wit but you know one believes that okay
and the dynamics of the relationship it
was not drunk has billions of dollars if
Michael Cohen does let me finish my let
me Michael Cohen does have millions of
dollars okay salience so millions and
billions all right let me finish my
answer okay Michael Michael Cohen had
great authority within that organization
gotta take care of that so now the money
you got to see the way this all comes
down first of all he got approached okay
he got approached nineteen days or
fifteen days before the election okay
he got approached it'll take a hundred
and thirty thousand dollars makers up to
it to make this go away he had to make a
decision okay on the impossibility it's
not that he paid a hundred thirty grand
for something he didn't do and never saw
your birthday is like when you're
looking at in the vacuum like when but
if you understand the relationship here
it makes complete sense that he's
approached am I going to go to the boss
or am I not gonna go to the boss alright
what
do he chose not to go to the ball he
chose to take care of this guy wouldn't
he get 130 why would he pay 130 grand of
his own money yeah well you know what
you're gonna when Michael Cohen does
come out you're gonna you're gonna find
out the mechanics of that but dodging
you're getting out of balance
I am answer what's the truth the what
the truth is he loves he loves the boss
[Laughter]
[Applause]
all right who believes this right and
megyn kelly doing a really good job here
of showing that the story they're
telling is ridiculous and by the way
it's still not clear that Cohan wasn't
reimbursed I'm guessing at some point we
will learn that Michael Cohen was
reimbursed for those hundred and thirty
thousand dollars and we will find out in
what way it was done the term we have to
apply here is called Trump's razor Josh
Marshall from Talking Points Memo and
sci-fi writer John Scalzi sort of
together one or both of them built up
and promoted this term you've got
Occam's razor right I love this Occam's
razor simply is if you've got two
explanations for the same occurrence the
simpler one is usually better or more
accurate or said another way the the
explanation for a phenomena that
requires fewer assumptions is generally
the better one sort of like the simplest
explanation is generally the one that we
should prefer or gravitate to not always
true but it's a night it's a principle
Trump's razor is if you have two
competing explanations for an occurrence
the one that implies the stupidest
behavior by Trump and his cronies is the
one that you go with and by the time
that this is all said and done I think
we might end up with another instance of
that here which is that of all the
different ways in which the stormy
Daniel situation could have been handled
the one that directly implies the
highest degree of stupidity from Donald
Trump and everybody working for him is
the one that ultimately will be the true
one and that might include illegal
payments that might include instances of
absolute and sheer idiocy and David
Schwartz truly gutted here I mean
embarrassingly so by megyn kelly in this
interview their claims are falling apart
and every time we
a little bit more about Michael Cohen
the more he seems genuinely like a mafia
thug type character working for Donald
Trump and I don't believe for a moment
that Trump is just totally in the dark
about what it is that's going on discuss
this with us on our subreddit at david
pakman.com slash re d di t today's
episode of the david pakman show is made
possible in part by brilliant you watch
the David Pakman show or listen to the
David Pakman show
so clearly you're interested in politics
and in following what's going on in the
world and the economy the environment
but what's crucial to understand is that
almost everything we talk about on this
show is sort of on the foundation of
math science and philosophy and keeping
up with the news is one thing but you're
never really fully equipped to
understand political issues and have
debates with people until you've
actually developed a more complete
understanding of how the world works and
how these issues work at the most
fundamental level and brilliant is one
of the most effective and enjoyable ways
to do that that I've ever come across
you can learn hands-on about statistics
crime climate science energy it's a long
list and you can get started right now
by signing up for free at brilliant org
slash David Pakman first two hundred
people who visit brilliant org slash
David Pakman will also get 20% off an
annual premium and membership check it
out sign up for free today at brilliant
org slash David Pakman